shannon for anyone who knows nothing
about screenwriting how would you begin
to teach them the craft yeah that's a
great question because we all kind of
start from this place of not knowing
screenwriting unless you decide to go to
a film program that's actually teaching
screenwriting it's one of those things
that is not a part of our education
system or anything like that so a lot of
us are starting from scratch the great
thing about it being 2021 is that there
are resources everywhere so i actually
just got this question via email the
other day and my first response was just
start writing
right it's kind of like even if you are
doing creative writing if you have uh
short stories that you're interested in
if you want to be a journalist and you
want to write articles you just have to
start practicing it right so that's the
first thing that you can do is just
start writing down your ideas the other
thing you want to do is then figure out
how to hone that craft are there
screenwriting classes
anywhere
whether they're in your area or they are
virtual are there screenwriting groups
that are in your area or virtual or go
to youtube university right which is
what we were talking about earlier and
so there are a lot of different um
organizations that have pages like film
courage like my page that are teaching
the fundamentals of screenwriting
because the biggest thing is
understanding the format which always
tricks people up a lot trips people up a
lot and understanding the structure the
third thing you can do which is just an
addition to honing your craft is read
screenplays
but make sure that you are reading
actual screenplays and not transcripts
so a lot of the times when people will
google and look for a particular
screenplay the transcript will come up
and just so you know the difference the
transcript will be only dialogue and
it'll all be formatted left
and it'll just be you know the dialogue
from the screenplay because someone
actually um watched the film and just
wrote down what everyone was saying but
if you're going to be the screenwriter
you need to learn how they are
formatting the scene headings what
action looks like where everything is
placed so you want to make sure that
you're looking at the actual screenplay
and not the transcript when you're
looking at those screenplays ask
yourself what you like to write
ask yourself what you like to watch so
that you can then read screenplays that
fill
in that format and that genre because
each genre is going to have kind of
their own rules and so you want to make
sure that you're learning how to write
the thing that you're interested in
so what if someone says okay i've
already been working at writing a
screenplay i actually have four or five
at home but i live in a small town i
have a family i have a full-time job
i don't know what to do from here
yeah so the first thing you want to do
is get some feedback on your screenplay
um because this industry is one where
there are going to be gatekeepers that
are going to be in place before you can
get to the big studios or the networks
or production companies so in order for
your screenplay to get made at all
someone is going to have to read it and
so you want to make sure that your
screenplay is in a great place and that
it's going to make it past the reader
right so a great way to do that is
finding people like myself as a script
consultant or finding script coverage
companies so that you can get another
set of eyes on those screenplays so it's
great if you have three or four
screenplays if you only have one keep
writing
you know get to your three or four right
and then send them out so that you can
get feedback on them to see if they are
up to industry standard to see if there
is an actual story there now from there
that's when it becomes tricky because
this is a who you know kind of industry
and if you are in whatever city outside
of you know los angeles new york atlanta
maybe then it may be a little harder to
figure out how you're going to get in so
some of the options that you have are
screenwriting competitions competitions
don't mean that you will automatically
get your screenplay made but it's about
exposure
and access right so if you pay attention
to
which screenwriting competitions are
going to have who on their jury
reading those screenplays then you want
to try to get in front of those people
so that they can help you to get into
the door the same thing is true for any
film festivals you can attend film
festivals and maybe meet some of the
producers who are there managers and
agents who are there to be able to talk
to them about your work don't have your
screenplay printed out and pass it to
anyone don't do it don't do it
keep your printed screenplay at home but
while you're there you want to be
networking and meeting people because
since this is a who you know kind of
industry then you need to get out there
and meet some folks right there are also
different kind of pitch competitions
that are out there that will also give
you an opportunity to pitch to people
who are in the industry who then may
help you to develop your work to take it
to the next place if you don't want to
do hollywood at all and you don't want
to deal with the big machine then raise
your own money hire your own people and
make your own content because there are
many ways for you to get your own
content out there now
so you said keep writing uh if if i just
have one or two screenplays what if my
life story is so fascinating i just have
to get this story you don't understand
shannon yeah i have to get this story
out yeah it's once you hear my life
story you will want to make this movie
too right
and i'm not looking to do other
other stories yeah if you're not looking
to do other stories if you don't want to
be a professional writer
i'm going to say kind of the same thing
applies to you because unless you're
going to find the money to make it
yourself you still got to get in to know
somebody to get them to make it so
you're still going to have to deal with
those gatekeepers so if your life story
is so fantastic and so many of us think
that it is right if your life story is
so fantastic then you need to find a
producer who you can prove to that
person that it's that fantastic someone
has to get interested enough in the
story so you want to be able to you know
have your log line ready have your pitch
ready have your screenplay ready
whatever materials you're going to have
to be able to show them like this is
something that you want to tell and if
they decide to buy it and develop it etc
then they will
but if you don't want to be a
professional writer you may say to
yourself but i don't want to go through
all those hoops i don't want to deal
with that i want it made now
raise some money
hire your people and make it yourself
because if it's the kind of story that
you just it's your baby and you just
want to make it then make it and air it
to your family air it in your hometown
air it in your city you can rent out a
theater
within the amc or whatever um theater
you have in your community you can rent
out one of the rooms and show it on the
big screen and still have that same
experience if you're not trying to
become a professional writer so you just
have to ask yourself what do you want of
that project realize what the different
avenues are and then choose one and
hopefully we'll get to see your story on
the screen okay what if you know i've
heard a lot of bad stuff about hollywood
and and
i don't trust those people
so
you know i i need you to get it out
there for me because i i just you know
i've been warned me as in me or is this
a general question it could be you it
could be it could be me going to someone
but but we could i could roleplay say to
you like i could you know and and so i
i've heard stories and i just don't
trust it and i know that you could
navigate on my behalf right so what
you're looking for is someone to be your
representative those people are managers
those people are agents those people are
entertainment lawyers i'm a script
consultant so that's not my part of the
job my part is to get people from idea
to pitch
your representatives then get you into
the room to be able to pitch and then
you're going to pitch to executives or
producers or even actors or directors
whoever it is you can get in the room
with so that it can get bought developed
and then made into uh into your film or
your television show so you want to make
sure whoever it is you're approaching is
the right person so that means you have
to start with research because the thing
about this industry if you decide to go
the hollywood route the thing about this
industry is people care about you doing
your part and you doing the work so if
you were to approach someone who doesn't
do that thing but you're asking them for
that thing then they're going to
consider that this is not something that
you're serious about right so for
example not every production company or
every studio makes the same kind of
films or tv shows right so if this is a
faith-based production company but you
want to
make a a vampire comedy right and so now
you're pitching your vampire comedy to
this christian-based production company
then they know that you have not done
your research right you don't understand
their brand and now that is going to
look um bad on you professionally right
so if you don't want to do that bidding
yourself great so that means you need to
find someone else who does that thing
who is that go between who is that
liaison who can do it for you so do the
research to figure out where the places
that would make my kind of movie or my
kind of tv show
who are the people who i need to contact
who have made their stuff there right
because a lot of those studios are
working with the same kind of production
companies over and over again right so
then you figure out well who do i need
to have a relationship with to go there
so there's still going to be some work
on your part because if you don't know
anyone then you still have to find the
people in order for them to do the rest
of the work
so it's a tough part of the industry
which is why it's not favorable for
everyone it does take a lot of work on
your end and a lot of grit on your end
and even if you do have a representative
if you are trying to be a professional
writer even if you do have a
representative the work doesn't stop for
you there you know right so they're out
doing some bidding but you're still
going to get most of the gigs because of
the work that you're doing yourself so
if you're in a position of saying well
that's not what i want to do then maybe
reconsider this may not be the industry
for you because there's going to have to
be work done on your end and you're
going to have to get out of your comfort
zone
okay and then lastly and i love this
advice um i've given uh my work's
letting me take two weeks to come out to
la and i'm armed with like five scripts
um i've talked to a couple people on
social media who say they might want to
produce it for me executive produce it i
haven't found too much about them online
one of them says they have their own
company and they have money that they
can put behind it and they want to meet
so we're going to meet at a restaurant
and
we're going to talk about them helping
me make my project how do i know that i
can trust this person
well if you've done your research and
you haven't found anything you now have
to go with your gut
go to the meeting
listen learn don't over share don't sign
anything
right consider this a part of your
research
when you're there
do you want them to take care of your
baby
right that's what this conversation is
about everyone starts from somewhere so
maybe they are new in the producing
field so there isn't much online about
them just like you're new in the writing
field right so it's not to say that just
because you can't find anything about
them online means you shouldn't work
with them
maybe maybe not you may say okay well
we're both starting out so we could be
starting this relationship together as
issa ray said you want to network this
way right and not this way so if both of
you are starting in the same place take
the meeting see what happens but while
you're in that meeting listen to
yourself
listen to them and then make decisions
from there it may work out
it may not
right but that's going to happen no
matter who you decide to work with now
if you do see a lot of negative stuff
online then don't take the meeting
there's no reason to take the meeting if
you can't find anything then take the
meeting and just listen learn have your
questions ready ask yourself what do i
need to know in order for me to feel
comfortable with doing this and then
when you're in that meeting ask those
questions a lot of the times what
happens is the writer always feels like
the person on the you know lowest end of
the totem pole which may or may not be
true so when we get into meetings with
other people we automatically get into
uh our own shells and think that we
don't have a voice to be able to request
what we need right but if this is your
baby and these people say they're
interested then you're interviewing them
as much as they're interviewing you
right so when you're there ask the
questions and if you don't get the
information that you need that makes you
feel comfortable with having a
relationship with them then you have all
the information you need shake hands
don't burn bridges right shake hands say
thank you and then find someone who is
the best for your project
and i like that so uh issa ray said uh
network like this yeah network
horizontally instead of vertically she
may not have used those words but that's
what she meant
i don't remember the actual quote yeah
okay and sorry and so that means then
don't try to like be like this social
climber like do it with people that are
starting out at your level as well yeah
it basically means the people who you're
starting out with are all moving at the
same time right so that means one of
those people is going to be in a
position
that can help you at some point just
like you might be in a position that can
help them so make friends with these
people if we're all assistants at the
same time we're probably all going to be
executives at the same time or one of
them will become an executive and i'll
become a writer or another person
becomes a director and now going back to
that who you know thing
right now i'm working with the people
that i know because we started off
together versus everyone wants to get
into the room and they want to talk to
steven spielberg right
talk to steven spielsberg's assistant
first of all that's the closest person
to him right but secondly that person
has aspirations too you know most
assistants there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be a lifelong assistant we
need people who are very organized and
get things done but most assistants are
there because they're trying to get
somewhere else and that's just the path
that they chose to get experience right
so that person may want to become an
agent that person may want to be a
manager that person may want to be a
director if you get a relationship with
them because both of you are in a place
where you can build a relationship in
the first place because you're not going
to get to steven spielberg and make a
relationship just because you're on set
one day right but if you're nice to the
assistant and you guys become cool then
now you start rising together and you
have the people that you need when it's
time to take a meeting you can call over
to this place because you know the
person that's working there because you
guys were both pas on some you know
random music video five years ago you
know so i think it's really important as
she said to make sure that you don't
ignore these people just because they
haven't made it yet
because some of them will maybe you will
maybe you won't right but instead of
jumping over those people and going to
the people who are already in place who
don't have time for you let's just be
honest right they don't have that kind
of time
so instead of trying to jump to those
people pay attention to the people who
are grinding at the same time that you
are
you